I feel like the scene is literally sums
up the entire movie
her fight between her true self
and this character that she's supposed
to be for other people
the thing I remember when we were
shooting this thing we're actually
shooting in a house that she stayed in
in LA with
Arthur Miller and it was always special
when we're shooting in a house that she
was actually in you know
[Music]
please clearly she's at her limit that
she can continue anymore and she's
exhausted
back to me and you realize how she needs
Marilyn to keep going she's
sometimes we did not know if it was
black and white or color there was a
very limited palette in her closet it's
really black white pink and blue black
in the 1950s is a strong color
it represents her desire to be taken
seriously as an intellectual as an actor
when we shot this it kind of felt like
it was two scenes because
Anna was obviously in two very different
looks
I did this changeover right there we
just stepped into another room really
quick and changed her over and then
popped her back in
we started with Norma Jean so Norma Jean
is her everyday hair a little bit more
natural
and then the Maryland in the mirror I
believe was a reference photo that we
were recreating and it was the first
time I believe I had done that style on
that particular work
um so it was all done very quickly and
fingers crossed walk away and it looks
amazing they'd mentioned all of them
yeah
I think when we all saw Anna as Maryland
for the first time we felt like we'd
found our Maryland I think everyone was
surprised and elated and and also
terrified because then we were going to
have to recreate that over and over and
over again and Anna was so amazing and
so generous with her time and I love her
so much thank you
for the most part I feel like you know I
was I was being Norma
[Music]
and kind of like when I needed depending
on the situation I would just turn
Marilyn on
that girl in the mirrors Norma Jane
playing Maryland that's Maryland
the rest of the time it's always normal
Gene
trying to be Maryland yeah that actually
is Maryland yeah
[Music]
the French shock led to Die For Love
they delighted in fighting
to us
but I prefer a man who lives and gives
expensive
you know this is some obviously you know
one of the great iconic moments
it was just so surreal to be recreating
this this scene
I had two days to learn that
choreography I was in massive high heels
and of course the steps I mean burial
the shoe could barely fit in in each
step I remember I was watching the
dailies for this scene and I think it
was take 20 something 21. either I was
falling or not remembering or the wig
and the Prosthetics were gonna fall off
and all the little fans Point into my
head yeah one more the dress
yeah one more it was the last one we do
use the last take really yeah it only
takes 21 days
[Applause]
[Music]
we've completely obsessively recreated
these couple of shots from diamonds I
remember Andrew having two monitors one
with the real scene and then us and
sometimes you didn't know if we were
watching playback or the actual movie it
was
really really amazing
she is so expressive in this performance
she does very exaggerated moves with her
lips and so I was working with my lip
syncing coach to get every expression I
mean it's crazy what we would do one day
that day I think we shot two musical
numbers we shot diamonds and we also
shot yes yes I want to be loved by you
and we'll be lucky
we're lucky we're lucky to have you
we're lucky you're a pro we're lucky
you're a veteran because we had a lot to
do every day yeah
every trick is in this scene
the backup dancers we like had a chart
of all the faces that were behind her
and we were trying to find guys that
look not only guys that could dance but
guys that look the same as the guys that
are behind her and then when you look at
the original footage there's very
obviously gray painted streaks in their
hair and because they're old theater
yeah exactly
the other thing that's recreated of
course is the song itself a kiss on the
hand maybe quite continent
's best friend
the recreation was really important to
not only
investigate the craft of the original
costume who was designed by William
trivia and honor him because he's an
amazing designer but also pay attention
to what worked on Anna
I think if you just kind of go through
the motions absent-mindedly then you get
a costume and you don't get a living
thing that actually is made for Anna but
I also think that effortlessness that
you really embody those costumes and if
you say she's wearing the same dress
just in white and without the bow but
they made exactly the same dress for her
to wear to the premiere yeah yeah
and then scene where she's sitting in
the audience it's it's basically in
color but when all the red is coming off
the screen it changes all of the makeup
and so it was nothing you could plan for
because as soon as the lights went out
she's in she's in her you know finished
look
you know this is basically you know
casting the moment that's supposed to be
triumphant you know this is really her
birth as a star
but what's going on for her is it's
actually a scene of humiliation
you know she's listening to herself sing
this song and she's horrified by Marilyn
embarrassed and embarrassed the thing up
on the screen it isn't me
when we saw the scene in the theater the
actual scene of the movie was not
playing so you know for me I was just
kind of like recreating what we did in
you know in my head but I wasn't
actually looking at the scene
I think three times in the movie do we
ever cut to like the film within the
film most of the time we're in the
theater with the girl watching herself
on the Silver Screen but you know like
it's great when you actually see the
movie in the theater and you're sitting
in a movie theater watching Anna sitting
in a movie theater watching herself on
the screen it's just kind of bizarre
Hall of Mirrors
foreign